hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft I am very
tired but that's not gonna detract from
my experience in Minecraft today because
I have quite the adventure for you let
me tell you that I'm not gonna tell you
that I don't know what's gonna happen I
never know what's gonna happen with
these things they just kind of turn out
the way they do I have no wood I don't
have anything everything's still on fire
good
listen I may still be a little bit
bitter about the fact that I had to
start over from the previous adventure
however I will not let that stop me
because I am better than the sum of my
parts not entirely sure what that means
but as it stand what just
let's see him what can break box while
I'm inside here what is that can help
alright whatever it doesn't matter it's
not important the only thing that's
important is getting into this nether
and exploiting it for all the resources
that it Duff can what is that sound what
the hell is happening I know that trees
degrade when they get chopped down but
why is you do that I don't know and it
doesn't matter I'm gonna make pants ha
ha boots and I'm gonna leave my torso
fair so that they can see my rippling
abs when I come for them and destroy
them I'm gonna use the last of it to
make a sward see this way they can see
the emblazoned em on my shirt and they
know that doom-doom is coming for them
and I'll keep the food keep the bucket
just in case and then I'm gonna get in
there we're going to the nether I spent
all this time getting a new area so that
I could get into the nether and then I
would be able to make the things that I
need to make I'm gonna bring some wood
just in case and bring some stone and
some wood I don't know why but just in
case I need to make a pickaxe for any
reason so I'm gonna go in here and I'm
gonna take full advantage where am I
I don't know it's okay no I won't fall
like an idiot I'm gonna go into this
nether and I'm gonna find the new nether
stuff because if I don't find the new
nether stuff then it would make
everything that I've done to get to this
point irrelevant and I shall not have
that I shall not tolerate that why am I
here I don't have ladders or nothing
alright whatever we're gonna traverse
this in the nightmare
hellooo Lava Falls okay there's some
kind of a land down there that might be
helpful there's probably uses for all
these nether materials that I'm not a
hundred percent familiar with but in the
meantime I don't really know what they
are well that looks like something I
don't exactly know what that is
a lava flowing down there hey hey poufy
all right ie I'm not good at
constructing stairs on the fly all right
whatever it's probably easier to find a
way back up than it is to create one
going down okay perfect
all right that's good enough for me hey
buds how you doing hey all right you do
good you have fun you do good what is
that and what is that whoa
okay well that's different I don't know
what that's all about but it's kind of
different I like different difference
good almost ran into that if I fall into
the lava and I'm on a ragequit I just
want to say that straight up I don't
think I can tolerate it I'm just gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna freakin bail what is
this ooh black stone interesting and you
are basalt I already knew of a basalt
they think I'm not sure why is it all
foamy
what are you Oh didn't know don't like
that no are you coming to me are you
coming to me are you coming for me oh
you better not become of me hey buddy
you you try you come you come for me you
get the Thunder oh yeah
oh you pathetic little baby oh you
slinky I don't like you I don't like you
at all
I'm not sad that I had to kill you I'm
not set that is love that is looking
lush okay well this is weird and there's
a lot more strange geometry what are you
you hairy person what are how are you
walking on the lava I can't do that why
is there one cobblestone right there
none of this makes any sense
oh it's hell I'm literally in hell and
also the ambience is kind of creepy I'll
help Lexi escaping the music nice and
high so that we can hear it all its
glory but not too high listen you know
Anna ruined people's listening
experience now do you know maybe that
might be too quiet oh you never know
with these things
right don't do it you'll die don't
you'll die no you'll die oh why are you
didn't die whatever you slinky person
slinky dude ah I don't know many insults
that aren't based on curse words you
poop sniffer I'm never gonna be able to
find my way back
I am never in the history of forever
ever going to be able to find my way
back I'm never gonna be able to find my
way forward actually for that matter
hope oh well this was a waste of time
I gotta get down there but then will I
be able to get back up you know that's a
problem for a future me to solve I've
got water and if I've seen any MLG
tricks it's that there's a way to jump
from high places with a bucket of water
and stop yourself from falling I've seen
it was that a radiation thing it's too
late to worry about that oh god that's
all my stuff look I'm not an idiot
but I've seen that before people have
done that haven't they done that they've
done that I know but I see
[Music]
why didn't anyone stop me didn't anyone
stop number one I thought it wasn't high
enough to die instantly and number two I
thought I could actually do this thing
why did no one stop me
no one stopped me no you all just
watched your watched as I did that to
myself why would you let me do that to
myself I don't blame Lake seeing at all
I don't blame lik cioud but why would
you all watch me as I do that to myself
could you let me be that stupid
alright I'll be back okay I actually
have ladders this time I need food oh no
I don't have any food am I gonna be able
to get my stuff back oh my is it even
gonna be there when I get there if I get
there I don't really know how to get
there hey bud you like my staircase ah
how do I get there what are you no no
why would you
what no hey what you get you go away you
die quick oh that's why you die quick I
need to go find my stuff I think I
jumped down somewhere nearby the
vicinity of here'sh all right which way
is my stuff still there please tell me
it is and an Enderman is there I don't
know why that is but that's okay don't
disappear my stuff my stuff don't
disappear I'll be very dumb of you
almost as dumb as someone jumping off
with the full confidence of doing the
trick they've never done before
almost
I gotta make it oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh oh no no no no no
[Music]
this feels like hell this is hell hell
why don't I just get the bamboo there's
so much bamboo I could make so many
sticks okay
I have ladders again I'm going for it
maybe my stuff will still be there
hi why are you here why are you here go
away I don't know if it's like the lack
of sleep that is causing me to have
errors in judgment I do not do anything
intentionally well no that's actually
that's a lie everything I do is
intentional except the accidental stuff
all right is my stuff still there yes
something is still I don't know which of
my stuff is still there but something is
clearly still there come on go down go
down
oh okay okay and then it's this all the
way down come on hit it Oh God
yikes yikes yikes hole Yates ho ho ho
there's my pants it's my pants come to
me pants okay taking stock of everything
all right we're back in business baby
everything is looking up for me
everything's looking on the up-and-up
hey whoa what do you think you're doing
a way you came from aways okay no no no
and then oh yeah thank you
oh no you don't know you don't know no
no just no I got an axe there but I
already have an axe I'm good how about
no how about a big old nope on that one
aye sir gotta be so much gosh darn lava
I mean I haven't died from the lava but
you know I still don't you're
oh it's big ok Andy I'm not looking at
you I don't know why you're here
oh there's a couple of you but I ain't
messing with you
yeah oh don't come to me I don't know
what this is what is all this what is
this scooshy scooshy scooshy weird let's
see what this is old warped warp bloc
twisting vines warped roots warped
fungus sure okay bunk I don't know what
that was about
some kind of glowstone thing shroom
light shroom light from my room light
room light from a shroom light okay I
got vines lots of vines why didn't I
come here why did I decide to go into
the nether was a good idea why did I
sign that this was worth all the pain
and suffering that I'm currently feeling
why did I need any of this it's probably
some very specific use for all of this
that I can't be bothered to understand
that I under man really close to me oh
no no I say no no hey stop no go away I
don't like you
alright anyway I'm out of here this was
not worth it this is not none of this
was worth it
ow tbh not worth it not gonna lie
konna sucks not gonna lie nether not
gonna get a good review on Yelp God can
tell you that I don't know if there's
like nether diamonds or something to
find but I don't care they can't help me
if I'm dead so I'm leaving and I'm not
coming back for a while because this was
stupid of me to come here really dumb
I don't think the gold is worth why is
there so much gold gold is like next to
useless unless it's not I can't even
mind it and I've ironed this is a harsh
reality that I'm currently facing it's a
bunch of yikes
what I gotta say about that it's a bunch
of Yipes that's what I gotta say and I'm
saying it loud and I'm saying it proud
what do I do about the rooms dude I
don't even know I don't even know about
these weird asparagus things I'll put a
shroom light in my room light and
that'll be it huh can I can you I can't
oh my god mMmmm
how about right there mm-hmm that's nice
or whatever there's been a trip I got to
tell you this has been a there's been a
doozy of a trip mmm
okay so we got a bunch of crocodiles and
didn't really help me none so what I
gotta do is I gotta go back to what I
know and that's getting Diamond because
that's what I'm good at
I'm good at finding diamond and when I
find diamond I'm good at getting diamond
I'm gonna get diamond I'm good at it's
keeping diamond when I keep diamond I'm
good at diamond you ask any man about
what diamond all about this they say me
that's what they say in response to that
they go like oh yeah no that was they
say oh yeah yeah yeah you want diamond
oh you go to mark he knows all right I'm
going to find a diamond
oh my god it didn't break
oh my god I didn't bring extra anything
I didn't bring an extra pickaxe I didn't
bring extra sticks I didn't bring extra
wood so that I could build anything like
another crafting table down there I
didn't do anything I'm so unbelievably
stupid okay I got wood I'm so happy for
myself I'm so proud of what I've done
and what I have accomplished I have wood
oh hello oh hello oh hello oh hello oh
hello okay hey how you doing I know I
was saying hello ow
who would do such a thing to me do not
kill me do not no no no no no no ow
please not like this not like this not
like this oh hey I don't get that what
is this there we go done okay okay
that's what spawns the things where oh
my oh my oh my oh my I need you tired
before I do Oh whoo hey why don't you
just die what laughed at me wait what
just laughed at me what just laughed at
me you what is laughing there's got to
be iron in one of these I just need to
get iron
I got a bow apparently a lot of spiders
stuff spider dude this is all there's
diamonds Oh baby oh baby okay I don't
know what's laughing at me and I don't
care so long as it doesn't bother me so
all I need some iron
oh my god I don't like that I don't know
what's happening okay there's more so
someone's doing something they shouldn't
be doing oh hi Joe it's a witch oh
that's not good okay I'm gonna kill you
you're gonna die
killed witch okay this is great you know
why cuz I already have what I need
do not come to me oh this is this is
behind-the-scenes duplicitous miss if
ever there was one what's that hi Oh God
who stop it okay in the heat of battle
ain't no one do like I do we're so close
oh my goodness this is a bounty of
riches I just can't screw this up
I just can't screw it up that is all I
can not oh hey I'm not looking at you at
all oh this is a bounty what is
bountiful this is everything I could
have wanted at this moment and then in
record time I the Great and Powerful
markiplier oh I got it I got it guys I
got it I do mine three I have three I
got it
give okay it's fine okay cool we're good
give okay we're fine there were six I
have six we're good baby
we're good there's more over there
there's lava underneath it I should be
careful about that I will be careful
about that but we'll be very careful
about that ooh
I'll be so careful about that you know
how careful I'm gonna be about that so
so careful oh yeah Oh baby
okay so there's nothing beneath me I got
to remember that there's nothing beneath
these diamonds I think but if I can
somehow yeah yeah yeah yeah build
underneath it oh yeah yeah you burn you
burn baby you burn
oh you burn yes yes yes I have learned
the techniques of the Masters I am a
master of minecraft mine master as they
call me and look upon me and weep at my
many thymus oh my goodness yes oh my oh
yes let's get rid of this garbage let's
get rid of the garbage here Chucky into
the beyond don't chuck me into the
beyond you're chucking me into the
beyond I don't like that I don't like
that my iron good thing that was not my
diamond good thing I thought I thought I
thought it's okay it's alright it's okay
it's all good baby it's good idea it's
okay okay I think I spied one more yeah
I did I certainly did that's a pork chop
all right whatever
oh just the one oh you sure you sure
just the one oh come on
baby you gotta be nicer to me than that
this is what I deserve this is what I
I mean I I don't want to have like be
too like I told you so
oh hey hey yeah you've burned I don't
want to be - I told you so to the
universe but I do extremely deserve this
I'm gonna go back up but I will remember
this area and I will come back down and
I will get all the bounties and all the
riches that are here with my name on it
all here for me I know this we all know
this we all know that this is here for
me and I've done this and we're back
all seems worth it now I'm done eight
beautiful diamond and a diamond pickaxe
this is incredible this is everything I
could have asked for them this is
everything I deserve and I do I do
deserve this this is earned by me for me
because I'm beautiful
so thank you everybody so much for
watching applaud me in the comments
below
heartily because I deserve it check out
the other videos of Minecraft in the
description below and as always I will
see you
[Music]